- À Montréal, ils ont parlé haut
en Algérie. Aujourd'hui,
certains craignent des
représailles au point d'annuler
des voyages prévus en Algérie.
- Tous ceux qui sont autour
à militer dans le cadre d'Irak
ont annulé leur billet.
- Cette personne a participé
à de nombreuses manifestations
à Montréal. Elle est reenenenent
de revenir au Canada, on
l'empêche de preonononon vol
à l'aéroport.
- Là, ils te prennent. Tu
attends, tu nepapapapapapapapap.
- L'interrogatoire dure
des heuresntntntnte-t-elle.
On lui pose des questions sur
sa vie et sur son militantisme
- Ils n'aiment pas que
des Algériens manifestent
à l'étranger. Ces clair et net.
Ça porte atteint à leur image.
- De retour au Canada, après le
l'indignation.
- Nous sommes des Canadien
des Canadiennes. Et pourquoi
je ne soutiendrais pas le peuple
algérien? C'est une di
affirment être pris au piège
en Algérie. C'est
d'Hadjira Belkacem, fondatrice
de l'association de sépultures
eseseseses au Québec.
En janvier, elle se rend
en Algérie. Au moment de prendr.
- Ils m'ont demandé: "pourl'l'lt
les collectes? C'est qui qui
donne l' C C C C Ce genre
de questions surtout
sur les finances.
b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b .
- Il n'y a pas de garantie,
ababababababelle. Il y a aucune
garantie. Parce que j'ai
demandé: "est-ce que je suiseree
cette information.
- Une lalalalalalalalalalalalale
situation qu'Hadjira.
- Pepepepepepepeut me dire
pourquoi je ne peux pas sortir
exactement. Tout le monde me
pepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepé
longuement interrogée.esesesesen
d'organisation les
manifestations? J'ai dit:quququt
pour un avenir meilleur, on se-e
meilleure. On s'unit X et Y."n e
genre de récit n'est pas nouveau
ni surprenant. P P P P P P P P l
- Les arrestations,
les interpellations, les
interrogatoires aléatoires, on
tour ou pas. C'est un incitatif
à ne pas s'engager.
courant que quelques Canadiens
seraient ou auraient
en Algérie ou encore aurait été
interrogé avant de quitter
le pays sans toute
le nombre de personnes d
cette situation. L'ambassade
algérien à Ottawa et le consulat
algérien à Montr
d'entrevue.
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa